- You talked a little while ago
about a 19-year-old entrepreneur
their biggest asset is patience.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What is the
older entrepreneur?
What should they
have as their asset?
'Cause I'm not patient.
Three years ago I started a
business with some other guys
we're now 80 people
turning over £10 million.
- [Gary] Amazing.
- [Frank] I am not patient.
- You want more.
- Absolutely. It's fantastic.
- [Gary] It is amazing.
- What's my biggest asset now?
- Your asset is all
the cliché stuff.
It's just cliché.
Everybody said it.
What I think though is do
I think instead of saying
"experience" I'm going to
tweak it a little bit.
Do I think a 46-year-old man
has a better chance of knowing
himself than a 19-year-old man?
Yes I do.
I think we've all
gone through it, right?
Even think about your transition
from high school to university.
You just get there.
You get more comfortable
with yourself the second more
comfortable you start being
more honest with yourself.
So at this point in your life
and my life and your life
we should really know ourselves.
And so it's even interesting for
me to hear that you started with
a couple other gentlemen.
To me, my hope for my own kind
of personal picture that I'm
trying to paint here is that the
three of you had some crossover
skills but you're all
maintaining your core skill and
that is what's
helping the business.
You're taking care of this, that
person is taking care of that,
and the other person is there.
That is a very common thing for
older entrepreneurs because at
that point they've shed their
wants and their romance about
being the best sales guy or the
best salesgirl and now they know
I'm really good at
CFO, finances
I'll never let us
go out of business.
I got the numbers.
Don't worry guys,
you go be crazy 'cause I'm gonna
make sure that we pay our bills.
You go make sure the staff
loves us and now we've got this.
I was gifted that I do a
lot of the principles well.
All of them.
Finance probably being my
weakest, it's probably the one
that's most commoditized when
your business through your dad
and your brother if they steal
from you it's a good story.
(laughter)
I think that your biggest
advantage is that you got,
it's probably the narrative
to why you are succeeding.
Now the question becomes
a more interesting one.
I'm going to take you in a
different place that's probably
more grounded in
the actual energy.
I think the big thing now at
this point in your life is to
really try to figure out very
quickly what you want to happen.
And the problem is you have
two other people that may want
different things.
But if you're able to align
that you guys want to sell the
company soon because that's a
real cash out on that kind of
revenue then all of
your behaviors
have to go in that direction.
You have to the figure who you
can sell to you, you have to
start becoming a
media company to them.
When the great misplays of a
brand is if I wanted to sell
VaynerMedia tomorrow it
would happen in 30 minutes
not onrevenue, on the fact that
I would market to the people that
could actually by me.
I don't think Martin Sorrell
knows who I am, in 20 minutes he
would want to rip his
arm off the buy us.
That's what I'm good at.
What I would love to know is how
aligned are you guys and
if you're aligned make all your
actions go in that direction.
That's interesting to me. Right?
That's where you can be
something amazing happen.
So I think that's something
to really give some
serious thought to.
But I think it's
self-awareness at this point.
You got so much more
history in your 20, 30 years of
entrepreneurship that allows you
to and you should shed whatever
pride you have left in
principles that you don't bring
to the table as well as you know
partners do the more you could
shed down to only
focusing on what you do.
Me and AJ are so efficient
'cause we not discuss the things
that we know the other
person is better at.
We don't even talk about it.
You know?
Big.
When one broaches the
subject, the other gets pissed.
Right?
'Cause why would
we even waste time?
You know I'm better
at this than you and
we have become efficient.
Like fucking
efficient, you know?
And time is the asset.
So why debate? Got it?
- Yeah, that's great.
That's great.
We're on the path.
- [Gary] And the other
thing I would tell you
I would highly recommend that you
forcing your other two partners
to over communicate with the
three of you at all times.
Force communication right now.
You're successful and
you're at this age.
This is an interesting time.
Force communication.
Anything that you think is
sitting in your heart that needs
to be talked about with the
other two partners
I would tell you to
do that tomorrow.
The quicker you get it out
the better you're gonna be.
- [Frank] Yeah, thank you Gary.
- You're welcome.
(applause)